what is up with all these podcasts
blowing up where it's like some guy
winning a debate with like five chicks
dressed for the club
think about like relationships and stuff
are good and he's like really well do
you know the stats on that and you're
like wow you owned this 20 year old
chick in a mini skirt I don't understand
that hey married like why are we taking
you're talking specifically about the
whatever podcast no I I think I've seen
a few of them I don't know
there's some some of them are good Clips
I'm just the algorithm keeps showing
them to me and I do agree with you
listen the problem is that it's like
that if you actually want relationship
advice about what's going to lead to
like a healthy stable marriage from
people who are in healthy stable
marriages this is what I've always
wondered about have you ever heard of I
don't remember what it's called but like
maybe you should talk about that it's
just uh this therapist Esther perel
who's really big and she has some
interesting insights she's a couple's
counselor but she's been divorced
multiple times